bringing the latest technology to your
home
the swipe report on Sky News is
sponsored by currents PC world and bring
[Applause]
[Music]
Angela finds out if this drone matches
up to its half reputation while Alysha
gives us her take on Nintendo's
brand-new console but before we get to
that we should really talk about the
world's biggest mobile industry event
that got underway in Barcelona this week
Mobile World Congress is where tech
brands show off their latest phones
tablets gadgets and more imagine being a
phone manufacturer in 2017 having to
come up with something shiny and new in
a market where everything is shiny and
new so perhaps go retro remember the
Nokia 3310 from nearly 20 years ago one
of the best selling phones in history
well it's back and apparently by public
demand even if the nokia name doesn't
belong to Nokia anymore really is from
the heart we've had so many consumer
asking for bringing back some of the
Nokia icons then we thought to ourselves
well let's have some fun with this let's
actually do it
talking of blasts from the past
blackberries brought back the keyboard
the makers claim the key one is the most
secure Android device on the market
other brands showing off their new
handsets included huawei LG and Motorola
as well as Sony with the world's first
smartphone equipped with a 4k high
dynamic range screen something you get
in premium TVs Samsung though presented
tablets and not its new phone the big
disappointment of Mobile World Congress
this year happened before we even
arrived in Barcelona and that was the
news that Samsung wouldn't be releasing
the galaxy s 8 at the show now this is
the most anticipated phone from Samsung
at the moment and it's got to recover
from the incident last year where it had
to recall a whole bunch of phones due to
a battery problem
the reason thousands of visitors come
here every year is to get a glimpse of
the flu
kid iris scanner soon become the norm on
handsets and what about 5g we're gonna
see this enormous race almost a bit of a
kind of global arms race to get 5g out
there first the Chinese want to be first
the Japanese want to be first the
Koreans want to be first people in
Europe want to be first and in North
America and the massive push it's going
to be a bit of a while before you see 5g
on a smartphone but by 2019 2020 there
will definitely be devices out there
some in the industry believe 5g wireless
connectivity will be as revolutionary as
electricity becoming the driving force
behind all kinds of items from cars to
virtual reality robots this guy mimics
moves made by the person controlling it
the makers say one day he could replace
firemen or surgeons and I guess it
wouldn't be a decent tech event without
a funny-looking robots or ghoul part now
would it
stay with us still to come we've got the
drone going to places that humans can't
it's coming right up after a roundup of
what else has been going on in the world
of tech this week the American rocket
company SpaceX says it's planning on
taking two tourists for a trip around
the moon next year the week-long mission
will be the first privately funded
spaceflight and will rely on a rocket
that's not yet been tested and the
father of a toddler who lost his arm
just after birth has created a type of
prosthetic technology inspired by the
way spiders move their legs to help his
son and other young amputees it's 3d
printed and uses sacks of fluid in the
socket to operate a grabbing mechanism
Ben Ryan says he quit his job as a
teacher to work on the project and he's
trying to raise money for it by
crowdfunding snaps the company that owns
snapchat was given the highest valuation
for a US tech firm since Facebook in
2012 when it floated on the stock market
this week at 19 point five billion
pounds on its debut it's made snapchats
26 year old boss Evan Spiegel a multi
billionaire nee-san has been quietly
testing its new driverless cars on
public roads in London this week the
company says it's the first time
economist cars have been let loose on
public roads anywhere in Europe and it
says it did get permission from the
authorities time now to head into the
ice in France and Switzerland where
Angela has been looking at a drone with
search and rescue potential navigating
tight spaces and small enclosures more
efficiently so humans don't have to this
robotic solution is the brainchild of a
company in Switzerland to start it just
do that little movement
it says the robots called le Oscar's
place is too dangerous for humans so
mark we know that there are drones on
the market that have thermal imaging and
you know live streams so we can follow
what the drain is filming what makes
this one so unique Neos is unique in the
market because of a very simple thing
this is this mechanical system which we
call a gimbal that allows the the cage
to be decoupled from the drone on three
axis so the first one the second one and
the third one with the the larger ring
on the outside and if you think of the
drone flying the the cage is completely
decoupled so it can rotate freely around
the drone and technically what it brings
to the drone is the ability to have a
collision with an obstacle so we decided
to put it to the test a little collision
tolerant hit appears to be but I wasn't
quite ready to experience it firsthand
this reconstruction footage shows it
flying into a crevasse deep dark and
narrow and horribly dangerous the
zermatt garcia mountain rescue team used
it to locate someone under the ice with
the help of an attached thermal imaging
camera feeding back its view to them but
just how useful would it be in a
real-life situation most of the rescues
we were doing we're aided by night or
whether we're in with strong winds fog
sometimes it would be snowing as well so
I don't know if this would be a
limitation for the truant I think
everybody will be getting a lot of help
from this kind of new technology the
market for this kind of technology also
extends to industrial inspection and to
security when it would be safer to send
a robot in to assess the situation first
but the cost of these drones might limit
when man can rely on machine to help
your mind grabbing it for me angela
burns Sky News in Germany France now
usually at this point in the show we
like to bring you a review of some of
the latest videogames releases but
because this week saw the launch of the
much-anticipated Nintendo switch console
we wanted to get the lowdown on that too
so here's Alyssia with her thoughts on
the switch and then some games it's been
six months since the cloak was first
whips off the Nintendo switch console
but what is this hybrid console really
like to play and more importantly is it
worth its two hundred and eighty pound
price tag well first start you're
getting quite a lot for your money it's
a hybrid console which means it's both
possible and you can play it at home the
actual switch console is a tablet like
screen with two detachable controllers
that kind of flick either sides and then
if you want to play it kind of when
you're sat in your sofa at home you can
slot it into this docking station which
connectors your TV the most hotly
anticipated title for the Nintendo
switch is definitely The Legend of Zelda
breath of the wild
story-wise it starts with link waking up
from a deep sleep he finds himself in
the Fallen land of Hyrule that he
discovers his chicest light which is
sort of a glowing tablet that aids him
as he travels through the world
basically it's like a super fancy iPads
I won't spoil the rest of the story but
essentially you'll find yourself
traveling across this world and what a
beautiful world it is but if you're
riding a horse across a valley you'll
see that the grass is blowing in the
wind or the horse's tail you can see
every individual hair even though it's
this kind of cartoonish aren't animation
it's an open world so there is a main
questline but you'll also be constantly
distracted by the richness of the world
around you just so if you're a fan of
Zelda and you've got a switch definitely
this is a must-have but away from all
the Nintendo switch chatter there is a
new game that's ripping the cellophane
off of its box
it's called horizon zero dawn and it's
set in a post post-apocalyptic setting
which basically means in this world
humanity has been wiped out and
thousands of years into the future
you're now living in this prehistoric
world that's filled with the remnants of
this incredibly futuristic technology
and that's part of the reason why
horizon zero dawn is so compelling
there's a mystery at the center of this
world what happens to humanity what
happens to civilization as we know it so
as you're going through this world
you'll see ruins of old tanks or really
futuristic spacecraft so that all
overgrown with ivy the only thing that
can be a little bit dodgy about horizon
zero dawn is the facial animations for
all the beauty of the game visually
sometimes they can be a little bit out
of sync but it's not enough to pull you
out of the story and the story itself is
so intriguing you will absolutely
forgive it for it
so that's it for this week but don't
forget you can watch any of our swipe
episodes on demand and all the usual
places I'll be back next week see you
then bye bye bringing the latest
technology to your home
the swipe report on Sky News is
sponsored by currents PC world and ring